ou alors on parle du cannabis 17
millions de français donc ont déjà fumé
un joint pour 700 mille d'entre eux dont
fument tous les jours vous c'est votre
cas moi tous les jours voilà j'en ai
même vu avec l âge 46 ans
ouais et vous vous êtes vous êtes bien
vous sentez je vais pas en faire la
publicité comme ça c'est interdit en
france mais sinon j'ai pas l'impression
d'un jeu simple porte tort
alors pourquoi déjà être contre le
cannabis pourquoi êtes vous contre le
cannabis
jean costentin eh bien je vais
essentiellement les quelque chose sous
l'angle sanitaires c'est vrai qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'utilisateurs
chronique qui ne semble pas en première
impression en souffrir effectivement
encore qu'on se pose la question de
savoir s'il n'aurait pas fait une
croisière à plus haute altitude
s'il avait et n'avait pas chaussé et les
semelles de plomb qui sont celles du
cannabis mais à côté donc de ses
réserves et du cannabis
et bien il y à tous les drames de en
particulier de l'enfance à quel âge
monsieur avez vous commencé bien sûr
m'interpellait comme ça monsieur le
professeur jean costentin je vous dirais
que j'ai commencé par la cigarette à 8
ans à 12 ans j'allais acheter des
cigarettes et je fumais déjà quasiment
un paquet de cigarettes à 15 ans et
comme je suis originaire de la région du
beaujolais ont fait les conscrits et à
partir de 10 ans j'ai pris ma première
cuite
j'ai commencer donc par des drogues tout
à fait légal qui m'ont emmené tout à
fait dans des consommations peut-être
déraisonnable et c'est en découvrant le
cannabis que j'ai diminuer ma
consommation de tabac est celle d'alcool
d'accord donc au rêve
donc vous pensez que pour vous ça vous a
fait du bien je pense que ça m'a permis
la malvie td vivait dans la délinquance
dont éventuellement des choses plus
graves et ça m'a permis de raisonner et
par contre ça m'apporte état en
vis-à-vis de la police vis-à-vis de la
société vis-à-vis de la justice et je
sache je continue à en pâtir aujourd'hui
c'est ça fait réponse pour le médecin
on a vu ce qu'il a dit c'est vrai en
attaque un cannabis y il est du moins
d'alcool il a tué au moins tiré du nom
mais si mais totalement
c'est totalement discordants on sait et
on va s'était vérifié dans x laboratoire
d'accord lors
des rats mais la voix de william lynn à
bord at war laboratoire x alors vous
êtes addiction ainsi way ski ski si on
veut essayer d'avoir un débat un peu
constructif notamment par rapport à des
parents qui s'inquiètent ou des agglos
bien sûr qu'ils ont raison de
s'inquiéter prévient que l'on arrive à
différencier les effets du cannabis sur
un cerveau adulte déjà formé des effets
du cannabis sur un cerveau en boîte
développement on est bien d'accord de
l'anac situant sur avis de la mairie on
est jeune âge avez vous comme on l'a
mais plutôt que de demander à quelqu'un
qui est là j va commencer rappelons ce
que vous avez montré à l'écran c'est à
dire que la prohibition la répression a
été une illusion de protection plus en a
réprimé dans un pays plus les jeunes on
consomme et n'est donc fait pas la leçon
à mon voisin parce que 50 ans de
prohibition sont responsables d'une
hyper consommation avec ce phénomène
d'illusions il suffisait d' interdire sa
protégée ce que vous dites c'est le cas
et c'est ce que je vois moi
en fait tous les jouets c'est ce que
montrent les chiffres c'est qu'on a
l'impression que mine de rien cette
prohibition a fait augmenter donc la
consommation de cannabis chez les jeunes
et il n'a pas fait diminuer la
consommation d'alcool pour autant
puisque les jeunes en consomment de plus
en plus car il faisait régner vous êtes
pour la légalisation de la ville disons
moi j'avais une position morale il ya
quelques années qui consistait à dire
être favorable aller à la légalisation
d'une drogue ça me pose un problème
et puis un moment donné tu regardes le
réel je regarde les choses en face et tu
dis est ce que la prohibition est ce que
la répression porte ses fruits
est ce qu'elle est utile est-ce qu'on a
des résultats à un moment donné si tu te
pose pas cette question c'est que tu
n'es pas responsable
aujourd'hui on a de plus en plus de
fumeurs bah on est le plus gros
consommateur de cannabis en europe l'a
très bien fait oui alors qu'on a une
législation qui est parmi les plus durs
laissez-moi terminé et je m'en tenir à
son plan de relance et une malade du
sens de plus
le trafic a pas beaucoup de plus en plus
de trafic un violent ou fument qui se
transforme en gang qui génère des morts
des règlements de comptes chez les
martiens on est bien placé de plus en
plus de problématiques de santé publique
parce qu'on fume
quand on est fumeur de cannabis l'aude
un peu n'importe quoi donc il n'ya pas
de contrôle sur la qualité de ce qu'on
fume de plus en plus de jeunes
désocialisés
parce que ces générateurs de business
ont quitté l'école à 14 15 ans ont joué
un rôle dans un réseau et donc plus
d'école plus d'avenir le que l'avenir
c'est de venir peut-être le chef du
réseau
quand je regarde cette addition de drame
parce que ce sont des drames et j'ai
ajoute ses 186 millions d'euros de
moyens de police
moi je discute avec des gens des stups à
marseille qu'est ce qu'ils me disent
quand on fait tomber un réseau aps le
lendemain karim pas quarante huit heures
après pas une semaine après il ya un
nouveau réseau qui se met en place
on a là une pression excusez moi
l'expression est un peu triviale de
pisser dans un violon vous fait notre
job
alors vous êtes trivial oui mais on fait
notre job on le fait mach est mais on
est convaincu aujourd'hui que l'utilité
qu'on attend de nous elle n'est pas au
rendez vous sinon je dois religion
prétendue de prévention aujourd'hui
parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
or c'est un milliard 800 millions
d'euros mais recette unique annabis si
on ne légalise des campagnes de
prévention pour pâques les jeunes fument
on pourra me faire beaucoup eric revel
vous êtes contre et vous êtes énervé pas
parce que des gens dire carrément
l'impression que vous êtes pas du tout
d'accord je peux oui bah oui pas si je
vous appris d'après ray koval
alors je voudrais montrer l'incohérence
de ce que dit karim et de ce que dit
monsieur de docteur vous dites faut
faire attention sur les jeunes cerveaux
ce ne sont pas encore formés parce que
là il ya des risques et il me semble
même que parfois la schizophrénie
peut-être ligne rouge la brise cannabis
sur les jeunes cerveaux alors pardonnez
moi mais mon cher karim si vous
légaliser
dans un pays comme le nôtre un de pays
l'ont fait et alors le cannabis a bien
rappelé l'on s'attendait
des troquets ce cas planer d'aller loin
en 2002 pays fait dont le dernier à
quelques hoquets aimé parce que vous
sentez l'incohérence votre signe
attendez vous le connaissez même pas ce
que je veux dire avec les spécialistes
donc le pays l'ont fait bien me disiez
tout à l'heure à mon avis à juste titre
que sur un cerveau qui n'est pas encore
complet
celui d'un jeune ya des risques mais
vous l'avez dit bien sûr si on légalise
le cannabis est un réseau de galice où
est ok bien ne seront pas sur les mots
vous voyez ce que je veux c'est non mais
dans l'es11
je n'ai toujours pas terminé mon
raisonnement non mais parce que chaque
mot pour alimenter failli et bien juste
et bien justement sous légaliser est ce
que les plus jeunes ne vont pas être
tentée y compris sur les cerveaux qui ne
sont pas formés comme vous l'avez dit de
fumer du cannabis et d'un d'entraîner
les risques vous même les teintes vous
avez mis en avant le fort maintenant
mais aujourd'hui c'est encore illégal
j'aimerais vous allez répondre ce soit
illégale trois pages la réponse de bercy
donc d'abord complètement d'accord avec
vous d'ailleurs marcel rufo
pédopsychiatre l'urée me dit est un ami
avec qui je parle parce que c'est ça la
question
il doit pas dire la même chose à nous
deux parce que
alors tagnon avant la nar conditions et
bien c'est même pas laisser finir dans
les bras les bonnes séquences vous allez
arriver à gagner de patients c'est
compliqué quand même alesi saga marcel
rufo dit quoi oui tout simplement que ce
coût notamment les adolescents la
question notamment sur la question de la
schizophrénie 10 pour développer pour se
rendre compte qu'une personne sur 1000
mhz qui pourrait être schizophrène à le
cannabis est pourquoi être un
déclencheur ou en tout cas un
vérificateur de la schizophrénie ce par
manque l'indicé marcel rufo voilà donc
parti occitan mais ouais mais c'est
important d'être tout dire aux parents
mais aussi jusqu'à l'accouchement marché
japonais je mets les chamois se tenir
les palestiniens sur la question
sur cette question la lourdeur attention
si vous n'arrêtez pas de parler j'ai
l'impression que ça va vous filmer
[Applaudissements]
ça vole haut alesana il parle que pour
eux mêmes en fait mais c'est qu'on
commence à la question sur cette
question là d'abord est ce que vous
savez combien d'argent
aujourd'hui le cannabis rapporte et
combien d'argent rapporte la cocaïne et
l'héroïne est ce que vous savez à qui la
consommation aujourd'hui en france
puisque ça couvre à quoi ça correspond
est ce que vous connaissez le montant
c'est-à-dire un match sans frontières
comment la prohibition enrichi regardez
les responsables des simples mafia alors
ça d'un milliard d'euros j'aime pas ce
que ça veut dire donner
c'est connaître par coeur par contre
cela vous mélangez cocaïne et cannabis
une question à laquelle vous ne savez
pas répondre à cette demande apparemment
à 10,2 milliards c'est du pipeau de
larmes mais dominèrent c'est quoi
demandé nos données majoration l'année
parle du nez dans la législation
c'est d'un milliard et deux milliards
sept cent mille chez doro millions
d'euros aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se
passe oui le cannet le cannabis c'est un
milliard d'euros la cocaïne c'est 800
millions d'euros le reste
ecstasy héroïne c'est quasiment un
million 1 milliard d'euros ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire que quand vous dites est en
moi presse question si c'est une
question de philosophie
si c'est la question philosophique je
peux éventuellement dire il faut
débattre sur la question de philosophie
faut légaliser ou pas d'égaliser mais ne
trouvait pas comme excuse si vous en
supplie que s'arrête on a le trafic sur
tout ça je veux pas l'entendre
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est que
c'est vraiment mal connaître la réalité
de notre territoire
aujourd'hui le même qui vend le cannabis
yvan de la cocaïne
yvan jeu l'héroïne est que dans ces
quartiers malheureusement dans ses
réseaux lan cette question elle est
posée alors qu'est ce qu'on dirait que
ça l'est et dans le bas de la france
toute la partie littorale bord de mer à
partir de là c'est plutôt le cannabis
quand on va plutôt vers le nord c'est la
cocaïne alors peut-être un mât il
faudrait légaliser le cannabis et à
ouaga qui légalise et je la cocaïne
parce que ben ils consomment un peu plus
de cocaïne décelées même état d'esprit
et c'est la même façon j'aimerais qu'on
attende injuste tout ce qu'il vous êtes
contre moi je suis contre par rapport
aux dommages que sa cause au cerveau on
a fait le rapport le lien entre le tabac
et l'alcool ni le tabac ni l'alcool ne
cause des dommages permanents au cerveau
le cannabis ou moins ça c'est l'alcool
ne pense pas
durant la semaine à audon non halal à
cannabis et si je m'étais dit que je
suis pour l'art je suis pas déçu sauver
la feuille commander pénalisation ni la
négociation mais je suis pour la
prévention
vous pouvez dire ça ça vous va très très
bien je n'ai pas pu dire j'ai jamais
fumé ni cigarette ni cannabis et je
ferais pas ça en effet pour la
prévention parce que l'un des pays où
les jeunes consomment le moins de
cannabis c'est la suède et ils ont fait
tolérance zéro est justement ils ont
avec personne a pris dans un rail
shooter chris prolls voir le passé pas
trop vite sur les aspects sanitaires
ils ont été assez éludée par monsieur
lowenstein oui il lui dire il faut
savoir que sur une cohorte de 1000 diama
qui ont commencé à consommer du cannabis
entre 12 et 15 ans 10% d'entre 100 de
ces gamins font schizophrène à l'âge de
18 ans mais monsieur cost en saas et
l'étude pas parce qu'on a les landes
c'est pour ça ça ne sais pas ce que vous
dites la loi bachelot gc ça veut dire
aujourd'hui que ça l'avait beaucoup
d'églises pas le cas il faut interdire
l'alcool quitus au sein de 1000
personnes
il faut hélas il a rien d'acquis tu
cette même semaine c'est exactement la
même chose et c'est tout mais c'est le
cannabis ne nommera pas à ça c'est clair
j'étais comme un caribou l'essence ou
idéologie jeudi j'ai c'est une drogue je
veux pas que je parle avec une mamie
déjà bien
qu'est ce qui se passait bien donc on va
légaliser
on va légaliser alors je vais te
répondre sur la question moi j'ai
discuté avec notamment des oncologues
score qui disent que souvent ce qu'ils
consomment du cannabis
les effets un emploi quand ils sont
malheureusement candy un cancer les
traitements contre le cancer
malheureusement ça ne fonctionne pas
parce que la demande est d'une
importance que vous dites avec nous et
permettre de diminuer l'année sinon des
chimiothérapies et permet de
génération qui sont william ça ne sert à
rien vous aurez plus tard on vous entend
pas donc la voie docteur cannabis
thérapeutique ça n'a rien à voir
dr sela principal indice que vous n'avez
pas compris que j'étais alors nommé
coûté maison mais parce que j'ai dit
j'ai dit que selon peu là-bas sur des
personnes sans médocs ces conduites anna
pis je parle pas pour une personne dans
thor est un choix thérapeutiques et là
je suis d'accord et ça c'est les
médecins qui en décide
je parle des personnes et qu'ils
consomment malheureusement les
traitements contre le cancer ont du mal
à prendre
voilà ce que je dis donc et doc gynéco
contre la légalisation du cannabis que
vous avez dire qu humain juin non en
fait oui j'ai c'est assez difficile pour
moi de parler parce que beaucoup de
phases comme si moi je parlais des
boulettes beaucoup de d'éléments du
sujet ont eux mêmes été évoquée par
chacun et de la santé jusqu'au s'éclater
simplement fumer reste aurait alors dit
grant a commencé et c'est à moi a priori
je suis quelqu'un d'assez ouvert
réfléchi et tranquille et c'est le genre
de de stupéfiants qui je préfère je suis
pas dans le speed je suis pas dans un
monde avait remarqué chose
et pondéré et ça c'est juste ils disent
réellement pour travailler voire
artistiquement pour voyager pour vous
modeler rappelé à les fleurs du mal et
c'est mes fleurs du mal à moi pourrait
même rendre hommage à guillaume
apollinaire qui le 9 novembre 1918 qui
avait écrit des poèmes du haschich qui
était un des membres éminents du club
des haschischins celui sans doute qui se
chargeait le plus ça moins réussi à
baudelaire mais apollinaire adoré ça
reste est plutôt dans volver que dans ce
que vous montrez 1,4 m'a obligé à
prendre parti pour les reçus pour contre
j'ai longtemps été opposés parce qu'on
vous montre légaliser c'était un peu un
aveu d'impuissance devant les dealers
mais j'ai changé d'avis parce que ma
réflexion se base sur un fait très
simple c'est que la lutte contre le
trafic du haschich et la consommation de
haschich est un échec
re temps titres au total donc il faut
changer quelque chose
les flics passent leur temps un temps
d'un gars faire du chiffre à traquer les
types mais ça sert à rien et puis j'ai
deux autres arguments c'est que un jeu
c'est un pays quand même très étrange
on débat sur le sur le cannabis alors
que sur les paquets de cigarettes sont
exposées les photos
ouais de tous les méfaits du tabac moi
c'est la double peine je fume pas je
supporte les fumeurs et j'ai le droit à
ces photos ouais c'est horrible même si
moi je propose une chose très simple à
jamais quelqu'un capacités dans la
conversation
parce que peut-être ce n'est pas la
tradition française moi je demande une
expérimentation d'accord
ouais je demande à ce que de manière
pratique sur un territoire délimité au
braquo dj doc gynéco ah oui là mais
comme sa navette l'anarcho tourisme
s'il avait le regard des laboratoires la
police au lieu de ça les lieux de
s'engager dans un débat théorique où
tout le monde parle en même temps tout
le monde les faisons cette
expérimentation et tirons-en les
conséquences mais l'arrivée de la
nouvelle a déjà lieu dans deux pays
non bien from july monde entier j'ai une
certitude
ça ne peut plus durer comme ça ces
chiffres ou serre chaude qui vous a dit
malheureusement donc là le débat c'est
pas pour ou contre le cannabis ni pour
ou contre le trafic de cannabis parce
que tout ça existe c'est un fait je
pense pas que la légalisation du
cannabis soit une mauvaise chose
au contraire je pense qu'elle ne peut
être que vertueuse parce que
l'égalisation ça veut dire que c'est
donc l'état qui contrôle la production
la distribution et la vente du cannabis
c'est ça le gall est une substance sur
le territoire comme pour le tabac comme
pour le oui avec 79 milles morts du fait
du tabac 49 mille morts et on en donnera
pas les entendre pour sommer ils sont en
train de fumer là au moment où en paria
plein d'ados qui sont en train de fumer
pourtant d'illégal je l'obtiens revoir
économiques et sanitaires je comprends
pas qu'on en fait jamais vraiment eu
peur mais je vais le faire
après mais je m'attends prendra
énormément ses portes avec la chaleur ni
dans le cerveau lula a gâté lundi
c'était plein été reloués j'ai rien dit
je veux bien donner du crédit à gaza
déterminé mais moi je suis en dépression
agata non mais ça c'est un débat qui
m'intéresse moi je suis content non mais
attendez vous parlera après finition en
dépression j'aime là je me suis dit oui
donc d'un point de vue économique je
pense que c'est une bonne chose et d'un
point de vue sanitaire ça voudrait dire
qu'on a une légalisation réguler une
égalisation contrôle et donc ce serait
une substance qui peut dans des endroits
beaucoup moins risqué que des deals en
bas des immeubles détruits et des coûts
maintenant alors allez-y
non parce que j'ai écrit en profondeur
non mais dans les choses que j'avais
bien sûr dans mon texte précisément il
ça parlait de la joie de la joie dont
j'ai besoin pour m'exprimer pour vivre
par son lad rdv sur la loire toujours
est un peu et j'allais parler des
antidépresseurs que tout le monde prend
pour aller travailler
et les millions de personnes prennent
part à des travail et des millions de
personnes prennent des ans la france est
le thème des pays où on consomme le plus
intime et profond plus faire il va le
faire dans 5 minutes au mal des six
camille absatou alors vous vous attend
ouais parce que je suis un peu pour ray
contenant simplement d'abord je voudrais
pousser un petit coup de gueule on parle
souvent du cannabis alias drogue de
citer deux quartiers dans les quartiers
très bobo il ya bobby brown il faut
arrêter avec son chien partout moi
j'étais plutôt pour parce que je me
disais oui c'est 1,2 milliard pour
l'état sacré d'entre 20 et 40 mille
hommes un emploi ça permet de faire en
sorte que la police soit plus mobilisés
là dessus parce que c'est 12% du budget
de la police québécois du du temps et du
budget de la police qui est là dessus
donc je disais ça mais on peut pas faire
l'apologie quand même dû du 2 du
cannabis je dire à un moment faut juste
arrêter du canton vaud non mais c'est de
la polémique je vais aller au bout de
mon raisonnement aller au bout de mon
raisonnement les cieux désolé j'ai
entendu des terres mystiques qui sont
pour moi de l'apologie quand on voit des
gamins qui sont destroy pollution des
sols arriveront à réfléchir qui arrivent
plus à parler je dire qu'ils n'arrivent
plus à suivre leur scolarité à tanger
oui je trouve je trouve que c'est
inadmissible d'en faire l'apologie et
dire que le fait de légaliser le
cannabis va permette d'arrêter le trafic
sa chute dans certains quartiers quand
on démantèle effectivement des réseaux
de stupéfiants
vous avez une explosion des loyers
impayés etc
pourquoi parce qu'il ya plein de gens
qui vivent de ce commerce cela croyez
moi demain si vous légaliser ces gens
ils vont faire quoi ils vont aller
chercher parce que cette les gazons
décision déjà de cannabis hirson
son règlement pour chercher du cannabis
qui est hautement dosés qui va détruire
encore plus nos jeunes ils vont aller
chercher
de toute façon un commerce parallèle
parce qu'ils continueront à vouloir
gagner de l'argent de cela c'est loin
vos gamins de la cocaïne des mères la
raison du 2 du cannabis avec plein de
trucs horribles non si on sera bien
content de voir notre analyse est ce que
c'est qu'un jour je pensais être le seul
ringard est taxé de telles missions
jeudi au moins une chose vraiment je le
pense parce que ce que vous avez montré
de teneur que ce soit c'est pas légal à
la limite je m'en fous mais pardon non
moi je m'en vois pas non mais bien sûr
moi j'ai des enfants je vais vous dire
je préfère qu'il fasse du sport
je préfère un cèdent leur pire le
auctions comprenant du cannabis est ce
que vous avez fait là moi on a le
problème de la ligue a dit ça me choque
parce que c'est une façon de faire
l'apologie
on peut vivre sans fumer de canadiens
toute sa vie je serai pleinement plus
malade que vous aa votre mais en tout
cas je trouve ça extrêmement des
matériaux mais quel spectacle en donne
nassiet le spectacle on donne on dit aux
jeunes légalisant le cannabis et son
aisance à noël m'a mal regardé mais moi
je le trouve que ce qu'on fait là on
devrait dire ce qu'ils peuvent faire
pour soutenir tous ensemble parce qu'on
film du canada onf et sa professeur
william lowenstein unique et vous chez
quelqu'un qui est dépendant cannabis et
combien en sortez-vous avec ce
médicament chez deuxièmement combien de
temps consacrez vous pour faire de la
prévention le plus vingt ans que vous
faites de l'addictologie
oui c'est tout un point de trois ans
mais c'est une phase d abord il ya des
bouts crèche si vous avez un peu de
mémoire au début de ce débat ô combien
animé jédir est ce que l'on pourrait
différencier nos discussions sur le
cannabis chez l'adulte et le cannabis et
pour celles en vie
je vais dire oui si vous l'avez vous
dire trois fois pour eric revel manon
carrier alizée a donc franchi sur
williams a data et je suis vous voulez
généralement la santé canadienne plutôt
comme un modèle que quelque chose qu'on
voit insulté en irresponsabilité la
syrie pardonnez-moi canadienne si l'on
décidé de légaliser c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont nettement plus irresponsable
que vous c'est que justement les une
consommation parmi les jeunes qui les
inquiète donc notre but commun c'est
comment on trouve enfin un système qui
est moins catastrophique sur le plan
sanitaire
sur le plan sécuritaire sur le poids
économique et même sur le plan
démocratique puisque les profilages
ratio continue de creuser la fracture
sociale
grâce à ce sujet là donc c'est un échec
complet comment on peut faire autrement
je finis pour vous dire qui hélas bien
sûr personne à l'heure actuelle n'a la
certitude c'est pas parce que quelque
chose ne marche pas que son inverse va
marcher
donc s'il va falloir un jour arrêter de
penser que la loi peut tout faire et
faire de la question du cannabis à débat
national avec une cause nationale
prioritaire on l'a fait pour le
sauvetage en mer ont peut-être le faire
pour le sauvetage de deux ans la loi ne
peut rien sans la prévention et les
budgets s'amuseront je vous posais la
question combien de temps avez vous
consacré depuis vingt ans la prévention
à l'évolution vous savez à gagner parce
qu'on va bientôt conclu il ya d'abord
sur la légalisation et pour vous
répondre
madame sur la source vous avez dit sur
la question de la légalisation
d'abord par rapport à la police faut
savoir que quand on va légaliser
voilà et c'est déjà il ya déjà des
des petits magasins qui le font je vois
que vous en faites la pub d'ailleurs
mais et non mais je crois que l'huile
d'olive côté des tribunes et des paquets
de cigarettes ça serait interdit donc
rappellera peut voir le débat mais pour
autant moi je penche pour qui le débat
je pense qu'il est essentiel
voilà l'égalisation et pour l'instant
c'est interne amélioration c'est
interdit donc je pense aussi et
d'ailleurs
la cigarette est interdite sur des
plateaux techniques sur la publicité des
cigarettes est interdit donc la façon en
l'occurrence je vois qu'on fait on en
outre pas ce que ce qu'elle aura permis
à l'essai au delà de tout sur la
question faut savoir que quand on a
égalisé on n'aura jamais d'abord à
chaque fois qu'on mettra des taxes parce
que l'état va mettre des taxes et la
houle et amédée panetta il y aurait la
contrebande on lire ce roman l'accident
bon on est d'accord la cigarette
aujourd'hui vous savez que c'est le
premier de trafic en france alors
pourtant que la cigarette on l'a fait
mouche et le bar tabac et pas de souci
tout le monde peut acheter ses
cigarettes sans que ça va s'arrêter par
un policier il me semble même des
mineurs d'ailleurs mais de ce que vous
allez vous retrouver avec la
légalisation du cannabis avec en france
permettre des normes parce qu'il ya des
médecins les mêmes qui vont dire qu'il
faut légaliser diront mais non par
contre on fall of the law dosage pas le
dosage je suis pas une spécialiste je ne
parlais pas de dosage mais je sais quand
même quand même certains niveaux c'est
plus beau c'est qu'ils ont besoin tous
les matins en se levant de fumer leurs
voiles parce qu'à la limite on parle de
qui fume pas elle fume pas de cigarettes
mais il fallait jouer mais quand il
enfume 10 de joints par le minimum par
jour ça devient presque un paquet de
cigarettes à l'affairé parce qu'il a dit
me semble que du tabac quand même dans
le cannabis et s'enfuit grogne
mais oui mais yahia dans le cannabis
c'est dans le joint éventuellement il
faut déconseiller ça il faut soit fier
de moi j'ai dit dans le joint
excusez-moi j'ai aussi mon temps c'est
pas l'être d'ailleurs
oui mais sur cette question ainsi que
qu'est ce qui va se passer ce que les
policiers ils ne pourront jamais et
c'est là le danger et c'est là le danger
ne pourront jamais faire la différence à
chaque fois les avocats de la bohalle et
au laboratoire pour vérifier quelle
tendance est là dedans et qu'elle paye à
dans l'autre je reprends l'avion et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il vaut mieux faire
comme en suisse el-oued j'ai souhaité
savoir de quoi faire vous plaît pas tous
en même temps arrêté c'est insupportable
moi je moi je vais vous dire une chose
et la ministre je suis peut-être moi je
suis pas une spécialiste de la question
mais si je suis rentré en politique
c'est justement contre un come back
contre la drogue
c'est ça qui m'a motivé ma première
motivation était là parce que dans les
années 80 moi j'ai vu malins les si on a
laissé crever les usagers de drogues
mais pour les allées cinq ans n'est pas
ce qu'on voulait pas aller au bout et on
joue on est d'accord c'est terminé c'est
que on nous avait pas expliquer ce que
c'était on a vu quelque chose arrivait
dans les cités tout le monde d'en
consommer d'ailleurs c'était à l'époque
c'était quartier les quartiers bourgeois
qui venaient vendre au quartier pauvre
et maintenant les choses se sont
inversées
w vous pas vraiment en danger
c'est parce que je parle de ce que j'ai
vécu de ce que j'ai vu un véritable que
vous allez me dire j'ai vécu une réalité
monsieur permettez moi d'en parler et je
vais vous dire je vous ai ramené un
livre juste une personne tu connais
karim a libéré ce cas là où il racontait
sa vie qu'à raconter son histoire d'un
jeune qui nuit justement a vu la
descente aux enfers parce que bien sûr
d'abord le cannabis on connaissait pas
après la cocaïne après l'héroïne et ses
parties plus haut est aujourd'hui un
chandail des gens mais ce que je vais
expliquer ce qu'on nous a jamais
expliqué
entre temps question c'est aussi de la
prévention je l'expliquais de personnes
pour démineurs et pourquoi je sais pas
pour la légalisation parce que
aujourd'hui un policier peut arrêter un
mineur et appelé ses parents qui sont
arrivés dès qu'on change pas une équipe
qui perd sa maman
il est très tard va conclure on ne
change pas on dira que je voyais on va
conclure me doutais qu'en fait attendait
rien les canadiens aiment le docteur
juste une chance de percer que à un
moment qu'on veut c'est alors bon je
vais juste qu'on m'explique pas que en
légalisant le cannabis
on règle le problème de la 1re mathilde
du trafic je vais pas comme vous le
savez après que soient les questions
philosophiques je suis prête à débattre
et jeu et pourquoi pas mais pas mais
faut pas il faut prendre les bonnes les
bons arguments et pas dire que c'est pas
ça qui va résoudre le problème on va
voir ce qu'on pense qu'un téléspectateur
ferrat pour ou contre la légalisation du
cannabis en europe pour à 60% et contre
à 40%
c'est ce que disent nos téléspectateurs
on rappelle bien sûr que c'est illégal
en france 1 jusqu'à présent et il mais
ça me rassure cyril parce que c'est ce
qui nous rassure pourquoi parce que
d'abord vous avez beaucoup des jeunes
soit il regarde s'ils ont les mains et
finalement eh bien on a pas de ville au
cours des tout à l'heure des 88 dernière
dernière question je veux redire choisi
une dernière question nous deux ça
douille de médecins que les adultes
d'ailleurs nos deux professeurs est ce
que parce que la question que tout le
monde me posa sur twitter est ce que oui
ou non le cannabis est dangereux pour la
santé
professeur constantin évidemment et pour
la santé physique comme le tabac et même
plus que le tabac mais en plus il
adjoint à cela des troubles anxieux des
troubles dépressifs la schizophrénie et
parlons-en des perturbations de la
capacité d'apprendre
nous sommes engagés dans la
mondialisation et ceux qui gagneront en
fait que ce critérium
ce seront ceux qui seront le mieux
préparé nick hamm et ni shooter nippo
mais alors ils n'ont rigoler il est
professeur
weinstein est ce que c'est qu'on est ce
que est ce que c'est dangereux ou pas
même question et non il est encore plus
d'alerté s'il vous plaît les que les
intervenants où il est en plus un bon
gars me hockey faudrait peut-être sortie
sinon j'ai donné ma réponse je voulais
dit aussi chez l'adulte c'est peu ou pas
dangereux à condition que ça ne soit pas
fumer d'éviter la combustion sur un
cerveau forme et après on peut agiter
toutes les peurs du monde comme ça a été
fait pour la masturbation rend sourd
l'amour rend aveugle et le cannabis
france terrible alors la porte d'entrée
attendez vous êtes vraiment dr c'est à
dire d échelle de dangerosité quoi été
établis par plusieurs personnes dont des
soeurs david ne tord au royaume uni qui
dit que c'est moins toxique que l'alcool
et le tabac une fois qu'on en a mis tous
les critères de façon très sérieuse mais
j'aimerais qu'on retienne semaine parce
que c'est là dessus qu'il faut se
retrouver chez l'adolescent la
dangerosité en termes de randy cap c'est
même pas la peine de dire de mortalité
des milliers nord qui n'existe pas ne
perdons pas de crédibilité tandis que la
consommation précoce intensive régulière
de cannabis peut être sacrément
handicapante pour le développement
cérébral
moi je vous dis entendu ça je vous dis
franchement savez j'étais j'étais un peu
pour avant et maintenant je suis passé
du côté des minimes
tu veux qu'on continue dans les chais
pour consommer ils enverront un pote
trucs mais je le dis arrêtez ça faut pas
être dupe non plus les ferries ont
contre la légalisation ne propose rien